Um, about the film, um,
those of you who were there,
we realized that, um, the film
is very, very different. Uh,
um, on the book, um, uh, is, is great. Uh,
uh, Brit rating on the
quote of five, in fact,
as, uh, the, uh, many
clever transformations,
as long as they pull it out,
the lawyer,
he lives in denial,
uh,
becomes the occasion for
low joke about the eat and,
uh, how [inaudible] thing you really, uh,
the carry about half full steam.
That job there was repeated
throughout there. Really. Uh,
so it's a very clever transformation
to see a movie on your own just to
swing later. Um, Faulkner is, um,
is actually very impressive to know that
he could write something like this arm
if you're read.
Uh,
but he can also rate the screenplay for
the half and half, not five. So He's,
you know,
just kind of a,
almost two sides of his
background in terms of rating. Uh,
so this is just the, just to
alert you to, um, this, the,
the existence of the film.
Um,
but I also wanted to use this as an
occasion to talk about a remark that,
uh, Howard Hughes at Howard
passed, um, made about, uh,
devote that to half and half
not, and, um, in many ways,
adding insult to injury there was
completely changing the plot line of the
novel.
Uh,
but he also had some
generous things to stay, uh,
about the novel and
about Hemingway. So, uh,
because it was working with
having way and having a,
it was on record as being quite unhappy
with the way that his novel, uh,
was transformed. So how the last claim
to have clear from having way, um,
they had to have and have
not a with junk and tally,
that was the excuse for his
completely changing the novel arrive.
It started out being really
took nothing silly, um,
should have the freedom to,
uh, change, uh, as he saw fit,
which he did a two or a staggering degree.
But however else we made in the tradition
of people saying negative things about
to happen and help nurse, um, and uh,
we can look at a few other instances are
people expressing a lot tells about the
novel. Um, this is, um,
one of the most extreme down wash was
to have and have not is stupid and
foolish,
both a disgrace to a good radar,
a boat which should
never have been printed.
It contains passages of golden writing
and the pause of three good show stories
when one of these was up here
and ask why as the short story.
It was much better there
and not broken up by the,
in the concision of the
chapter. Um, so you know,
about as as hostile a review
as one could get a auto.
I should also say that,
but we've used our Jamera in themselves
and I often book reviewers feel the need
to be critical so itself is
completely within their convention.
Um, a book reviewing.
Um, here's another, uh,
to my mind much more,
uh, much as the Muslims,
more perceptive of, um, and
much truer to the spirit of, uh,
to have an half,
not from a great critic,
Alpha Kaizen in new having way,
not altogether.
They have passages and passages in which
the old ac ruins comes through with the
slippery rhythm,
the virtual assonance,
that awful ways of phases fused with
sessions before he is cleverness that the
click clack of the bead is like a hits.
And also unusual awkwardness for this is
a Hemingway who is rather less sure of
himself than usual and a
good deal more into hence.
So this to my mind catches very well,
uh,
both with his good about the novel and
what makes it worth reading in my mind.
Uh,
we'll also obviously points to some
really clear the facts about the novel is
also a very good pressurization of
Hemingway in terms of I see really means,
um, and the, the [inaudible] and uh,
having weighs pros that makes it
almost like poetry at many moments are.
So it's just a very good overall
calendar pending where, uh,
but also the special, uh, tig and, um,
I think very true to the spirit of
Hemingway and thinking that it's both less
well crafted, uh, but maybe
closer to Hemingway's hot,
one more quote from another critic.
And very understandable given
the subject matter of uh,
to half and half,
not saying that Hemingway was one of
the least of work whenever co writers in
this generation,
I think it's very interesting statement.
He was one of the least overtly political.
Does that mean that even though
he's not overtly political, um,
that actually, uh, there's a time
of deep politics in the novel.
So I would like to not over,
but something that once we look deeper,
further into the novel or get to see
that there's some hard experience. Um,
so I would like to take that
as a starting point, um,
and to ask whether or not to have
and have not is a political now.
Um, and as is the custom in this
class, I like to think about it, um,
on a number of,
on two different scales.
One is through the macro history,
uh,
that is the background to a novel.
Um,
and we know that because Harry Morgan,
there's so much to do with Cubans were
tied to get to United States in part one,
and then Cubans wanted to get
act of Anna and par three. Uh,
we know that Q and markets
is very much there. Um,
and along with that and Paolo of that,
that is also the Great Depression in the
United States that this is very much a
novel of the 1930s. These
are the macro context, um,
that make up the context of the novel.
Um,
and moving to a somewhat different
scale and the scale of character,
um, character and narrative technique. Um,
I like to think about a novel
as a different permutations
of half and half now.
So that sense is really the theme
and variations on a title itself.
Um, and I'll be talking
about Harry, um, as a half,
not in several ways,
linking that to the macro
history of the novel. Uh,
but then what I really would like to make
a case for in the rest of the lecture
is Harry as a special,
kind of have what I would call a
mediated kind of have that is he becomes,
even though he's so obviously have not,
he becomes a half true,
the presence of somebody else.
So this is what I mean by mediated has
through the presence of another person.
Either it could be Marie or it could
be some suddenly like Richard Gordon.
Um,
Harry gets to become a habit.
So this is the argument about
Harry not being a half on his own,
but becoming a,
have by virtue of either a
handling process by way of
Norwegian and is channeled
through the reef of because
of the weight she, about him.
And also because of the
way he looks at her.
And he contrasted with visual and both
because of the way Richard looks at Emory
because of the way which have gotten
hot stoves on wife Helen. So, um,
is there much a permutation or kind of,
uh, a dance really among characters?
Um, in order for Herrick to
emerge as half of the very app.
So first of all,
let's go back to the macro
history of Cuba in the 1930s.
Um, and as you can see, um,
the colleagues with Cuba was
incredibly complicated in the 30s. Um,
there were six presidents in
three years. Um, so I'm not even,
you are under no obligation to remember
the names of the residents. Um,
I will even an announcement
where there's one of,
they give you a sense of how
long they were presidents. Um,
so most of the residents were
residents for just a few months.
This days, less than a month, um,
less than just a few months.
Um,
in the case of Ramon Grau,
um, just for three days, um,
in the case of others via,
um,
and this is this beat every name.
He was president for just one day
when you're okay. Sterling. Um,
and then, okay, slightly longer, uh,
a few months as a record
and, uh, a few months.
So, um, I think that it's
just really clear, you know,
just from looking at the list
of presidents of Cuba, um,
in the [inaudible] 33 and
then the, with the sex, um,
that the politics was just
incredibly hard to figure out. Um,
and as I mentioned last time,
having way was actually knocking
cure when he was waiting to happen.
I was in The Bahamas.
So it's highly improbable that he would
have been able to figure out the pilots
of Cuba in, in any intimate way. Um,
he would have been looking at
it very much from the outside.
He probably understood the politics
of the status who wore a that he was
covering much,
much better than the actual
politics can kill it dead setting.
Um, so instead of feeling us
out, so that as a consequence,
the president of Cuba,
whenever never mentioned,
we all even know who was
president. Um, then, um,
instead of what Hemingway
feels us is the generic type.
This is the young boy, Emilio, um,
who was one of them passengers.
They have to be carried back to
Havana after the bank robbery. And so,
um,
the very dangerous trip for Harry.
Um,
but he gets to talk to the boy.
Quite a Ben on also kills him.
Uh,
but this is a generic type
Revolutionary Moffa his speech pattern.
We are the only true revolutionary quality
deploys that we want to do away with
all the Ohio patients with
all of American imperialism.
This trend goes as the
tyranny of the army.
We want to start clean and
give every manage hands.
We want to add this way every other
go heroes. You know, it hasn't,
we just raised money
now by double his head.
To do that we have to use
means that they never use.
Also we have to use paypal.
We will not employed later
but ends with the means.
Emilio is in any way.
Uh,
but he talked like a much older person.
There's actually a lot of authority
and I don't think that Hemingway's just
giving this to us as the caricature,
that's a certain kind of authority
that comes from the sermon for Cabo are
certain speech pattern.
The boiler was,
didn't have to think in order to say all
those things because he's so familiar
with that kind of phrasing
and kind of idiom. Um,
he's considered conditioned in that idiom.
Um,
so that it really is second nature to
him and we can think a little bit about
what it means to have that
kind of second nature.
I think that most of us tend to think
that it is not good to have that kind of
language real into our,
so there's almost a kind of brief last
action clear to come out. Just like that.
I think we tend to be very suspicious
of people who talk in this kind of, um,
very dogmatic and a generic
kind of language. Um, you know,
that were, you can, you can
hear two sentences and you know,
it was man is a radical and is wearing
his medical and some only asleep.
Um, so this is a man
who, um, in many ways he,
we don't even know if his
true name is Emilio. Um,
he just says to Harry,
you can call me from Jojo who's going
back to that famous line in Raleigh.
They call me Ishmael.
Many,
many characters in American literature
would say save another character,
hobby something. This is a very,
very minor local innocence of this,
but we all know his true name.
He's just known by name Millie.
Um, and that in itself is emblematic
of the kind of character that he is.
Um,
but I want to go back to the point about
what it means to have a second nature.
The second linguistic Asia.
Um,
and even though our instinct,
our gut reaction is to be very
suspicious of someone like that.
I actually want to make the point
that having a second nature like that,
it's probably not the worst
thing a human being can have.
You know, it is probably not the
best thing a human being can have,
but if Holly is not the worst thing,
um,
because if is a sort of religious faith,
that is gas in Sephora language and to
the extent that we've named that human
beings need some kind of fair,
it actually is very,
very good to have that second
nature. So I, you know,
I think they've done anyways,
politely caricature in that style.
But you're showing us what it means
to have with being within that kind of
language isn't problematic.
Kind of being,
most of us would be Jacqueline,
but it is kind of a Bible
kind of being as in contrast,
we can look at Harry and this is the
first instance when I would like to make
the case for Harry as a have not,
is that it just doesn't have that
kind of political conviction.
He doesn't have the stake and the Azure
that is second nature to neo and as a
consequence, as public
talks, I want to trend.
Harry was thinking,
what the hell do I care about?
Is Revolution at Worker's revolution to
have a working man who rast the band and
kills a fellow,
works for them and then kills that who
are them hours and never did any harm as
a working man,
he kills you.
Never things about with the
family is the Cubans run fever.
They are double cross each other.
They sell each other that
they get what they deserve.
The hell of the revolutions I got to do
is make a living for my family and I can
do that.
Then he tells me about his revolution
to hell with his revolution.
Um, is the reaction of Holly
knows who us, we'll have, uh,
you know,
the Cubans,
especially in the 30s a that sort of
revolution with feel that way to most
people who are outside of it.
But the point remains that feeling
that way about the revolution gifts,
Harry,
no alternative moral grounding.
This speech is almost leave me and
of any kind of moral confusion,
any conflict or conviction,
um,
I can say is I want to
drink at this moment. Um,
and um, that, you know,
I want to make a living with
my family and I can do that.
So it is almost a kind of a toto mission
of this feed without having the dubious
saving ways of some sort of
local conviction that can one,
two sons with excellent this
horrible condition that you are in.
Um,
um,
nausea that familiar represents a
superior alternative to Harriet.
Quite the hydrating is diluted.
Um, you know, having waves,
not leaving a lot of bell
about that ability is diluted,
but as some point in one's life,
a certain degree of growth of illusion,
it's actually very
necessarily fiction there. Um,
loss of human beings need and um,
is probably about for the oil to die,
still clinging to that
political conviction. Um,
and this is what happens to Harry where
he cannot claim when there's really
nothing for him to claim too.
Um,
when he's relying completely on his own
mental resources and this not all of
him,
he's pretty empty person
left to his own devices.
Um, so this is, I would argue that this
is the first instance of Harry as a half,
not only in the sense that he doesn't
have that do yours but redeeming kind of
stagnation. Um, I,
we also know that the Cuban
Revolution's such as they were,
um, without the only reference
point for the novel, um,
fair to have and have nice,
very much about key west key
west during the great depression.
This is Hemingway's house house in key
west that he spent a lot of time in
later, actually much, much
later. Not at this point. Um,
but this would have been what
people in key west with seeing,
uh, during the great
depression, the rent minds. Um,
and this is one that was actually
or Fargo historical archives, um,
most likely key west,
um, because keywords,
which is very profitable recently
before the Great Depression,
and this especially hardly
hit by the depression.
So the unemployment rate was 80%,
80% of the citizens were actually on
leap and you see the hours who was on the
week. So, um,
this is about the most acute case study
after the Great Depression that we get
in American literature,
except that having ways,
not really talking about the Great
Depression in the frontal way. Um,
and we can look at the way in which even
the word Greg depression without giving
them the great [inaudible]
is a suggested to us.
But that is that historical context.
Um,
so this is how the great
depression is register by Harry
other bruises.
Boat Harry had the last sack over.
Give me the first night,
he said to the neighbor is gone,
Harry depressed the self starters
and started the two engines.
He put his second engine in her,
he went back to running.
They occur whether the depression
had put charter boat fishing.
Um,
so this at is two ways in which
Harry as a smother of their color.
Two ways in which that gets potentialize.
First we don't know about is
we all can only conjecture
and hard to um,
Harry is both reviewed
who us as his mother,
but uh, we just think that maybe
that's just suddenly he chooses to do,
but then it comes out in the context of
the Great Depression that he goes back
to it because the,
your passion has made the much more
profitable Charterhouse charter boat
fishing. Um, in hospital in part one,
he was still doing the,
to go fishing when he was cheated out
of inner and play $5 on is to dance.
That was still the title fishing.
Uh,
that is no longer operative and the
only way he could make a living as by
smuggling records to
me, United States. So,
right then that is the way
that this very old league, um,
very elusive way as the
way Hemingway in the axes.
Um,
the Great Depression.
And I think there is really useful to
think of the technique that Hemingway is
using as a kind of,
in that sense it's not a front or a
food trends description of the great
depression is just,
um,
a kind of very ACAB equal appearance
that puts the depression in the index,
so to speak of the novel. Uh, but it's, it
doesn't engage in or put it into format.
Um, and we can, I hope that you guys
were talking about it in session,
why chooses not bar the depression in
that way? And it's very ugly passion.
Uh,
but in this passage we can also
see that Harry is a half not,
um,
for these three reasons.
One is that he's lost his
original occupational,
although there's also the reference who's
going back to having, they go to, so,
you know, he must've been doing that as
well. We all know why it was going at.
All we know is that he had been law
abiding for quite a while as a owner of a
child vote.
Um,
and now has been something that is
illegal because of the Great Depression.
So he loses his legal occupation.
Um,
right now we know also know that he's
losing naturally all this liquor because
he's so the cousins are, uh, on him,
so he has to get rid of eyes
that has a lot of money.
Uh,
but not only that,
even as more detail about
this fish even that is gone.
And so in many ways to have and have now
is a very detail from the macro to the
micro,
have a lot of odd things that
are being taken away from hairy.
Um, it really is it in injury
when he was in a big way,
laws and loosen the group as well as
within the landscape of laws there anyway
has created for Harry Morgan and um,
just one other,
um,
watering of him as the have not,
and this is Harry thinking about,
he knows that those Cubans,
that one,
the Cubans who want to get back to Havana,
he knows that they're going to rob
a bank because every time you lost,
then he doesn't want to look at the bank.
So he actually knows that that's
what's going to happen. Uh,
so gullible as now to know
the purpose of that trip.
Um,
but he is not in a position to make
any other choices at that point.
So I was here.
This is the ultimate measure
of hairy as have not,
is knowing that he should not be doing
this or having no other choice open to
him either stay here now
and I'll be all of them,
but what the hell are they?
Where's the money coming from to keep
Maria and the girls have got no boat,
no cash.
I've got no education.
What can have one army men [inaudible]
I've got [inaudible] power.
Um, so this is the kind
of the ultimate, um,
low against someone who would like to
operate as an individual is to be able at
least to make the decision
based on your own judgment.
Everything in Harris Jasmine tells him
to know this is not something to do.
His judgment is not at fault.
This hand on top,
it has to do,
go against his judgment and do something.
But every thing in him what require
against and warned him against.
So this is the ultimate.
And he,
every decisional process has been taken
away from Carrie [inaudible] boat.
The boat was confiscated by customs
after he was found to be illegal,
smuggling bigger that was confiscated
something away from him. Um,
and now we know he has no
money in legal education.
Business Visit [inaudible] oh,
so is at this moment,
this is the absolute low
point, I would say, uh,
for Eric and now I want
to go to a slightly
trajectory with,
I let her suggest is actually the
beginning of an upward to Jeffrey.
And the beginning of this upward
podiatry is going to be very,
very stark is Harry as a rough,
ironic have.
Um,
this is the moment where we know
that Harry is by has been one that,
you know,
all the Cubans would feel good by Harry.
And Harry was also failing when the girl,
the big Cuban art. So all of them, uh,
with iron on the boat, but
herrings can last to die. Um,
and he, this is the
moment before his dad, um,
where he has at that moment he was on
his back now with his knees drawn out and
there's a head to water
of the lake that was,
his valley was very cold,
so cold that when he stepped in his edge,
it known Tim and he was extremely cold
now and everything tasted of their
solving as though he'd been
sucking on a hose to siphon a 10.
Can you?
There was no to him,
although he would feel a coal rubber
pose the same to have answered his mouth
and now was called big coat
and heavy or down through him.
Each time he took a breath
to host called Koden,
firmer in his lower abdomen.
And you could feel it like a big smooth
moving snake in there about the sloshing
after me.
This is a chapter 20 chapter 20
verse you to read that chapter.
The beast,
the couples attitude is great.
Ray Wendell clinics, um,
admitted to having, um,
really impressive pros and
to have and have not been,
must have been thinking of. Chapter
20 is just rich chapter. Um,
and it's about the vote with dead
men and the fish. I mean to, uh,
fish under turpines from wounds on them.
Uh, but is, is a way the
friction of human mortality,
uh, against the sea. Very [inaudible],
honestly living sea creatures.
Um,
but the passage right here is the
description and I think that it maybe is a
challenge from anyway,
although I wouldn't want
to push this too much. Um,
is a challenge to us to think about
what it means to die and what exactly do
when you have at the moment of death.
Um,
Harriet doesn't have something,
although it's not anything
that anyone would want to have.
It has this rubber hose
that is inside him,
that's making him colder and colder.
Um,
it is not a possession that
we would bond to you for is,
it was if most of us would like to
have taken all but is the possession
nonetheless.
So I would like to at least
put forth the possible,
uh,
argument are bad because of the
kind of life that Harry has lived.
Um, even though there's so
many strikes against him,
even though all the odds are against him,
the bone of that Ashley is his own
moment in a sense that he's living his
physicality to do this is not a dying
without knowing that you are dying off if
he doesn't lose consciousness after that
it is experiencing that too is pull us
expand. Um, and uh,
and just having that register
on every fiber of your being.
I don't know how much we want
to push on this point. Um,
but I like to see this as the beginning
of the kind of upward swing of the
narrative that this is the moment
where we can begin to start thinking of
heralded as a half now.
And you start thinking of him as a half,
although have in a very ironic sense,
having a possession that most of
us would much rather than I have.
But from this point I like make like to
make a Muslim ward systematic arguing
about Harry as the have.
Do they have anyways,
great deliberate fashion.
So I would very much want to argue that
this is actually the basic structure of
to happen, has not, um,
is to show airy as a half
should immediated presence
of other people looking at
him through the reef and
looking at him through ritual.
So what Marie and things parent,
I'm lucky she was thinking those girls,
they don't know what they look at.
I know what I've got and what I've had.
I've been lucky.
I've been lucky woman.
They ain't no other man like that.
He will never find them. Don't know.
I've had plenty of them. I've
been lucky to have him. Um,
is suggested to us that um,
movie was a spoiling Logan,
um,
as a profession.
Um,
so she's had lots of men in
her professional capacity.
Um,
and it is from that wealth of
knowledge of man that she can stay,
that Harry is really,
is at that point.
It's the best,
uh,
this child more and
there's just no one hammer.
So it's a dubious kind of confidence.
You know,
you don't want to have a positive time
saying that testimony to the fact that
you're the best, um, when that
happens to be your wife. Um,
so once again,
having ways really taking away with
one hand what is doing with another,
but there is no question that heroin
has made Marie's my life that she's
enjoying that moment that
she's having a good one,
she's having a good life
only because of him.
He is the thing that
gives her a good life. Um,
and that is the measure of what Harry has.
So it's very much more complicated media.
He has something because of the good
life that Marie has because of him.
And without Marie, we wouldn't
have been able to say that. Um,
so this is the first upward
swing of that trajectory to us,
Harry,
as a possible have.
And I would like to add that it is not
just because of the way that he's treated
Marie and the way that [inaudible] has
is now having a lot because of him but
also because of the way he looks at me.
So there is actually
coming from him as well.
We can sort of understand why
Maria is having a good life now.
Um, and was, he has made all
the difference to her life.
So here the wreath Harry is going
on is dangerous for the humans.
After when he knows that it's the bank
robbery that his estate and re wants to
go with him just to take care of the
jobs and your ticket because he has only
one arm at this point.
You want to do something for him on
a boat and she wants to come along.
So he says,
all right.
He told her as she got into
beside him a big woman long,
they get big handed,
they can still handsome.
Had the boat over the beetle
one hair you wrote about Harry?
I don't know. I'm just worried. Listen,
are you letting her hair grow out?
I thought I was,
the goals have been asking me,
how will you keep it like it is? Do
you really want me to yes, he's had.
That's the way I like him.
You don't, they look to you,
you look better than any of them.
So that's why that's why we has a good
life is because of the way how each
resort and we see exactly
how he treats him, um,
that he liked the way
she is. And um, you know,
and he tells her that was worried but he
doesn't want to tell her the full span
of it,
of his worries.
He changes the subject when she
wants to find out from the um,
all this make Maria's
life the good life 10.
It is all encapsulated in
this one small passage.
And the contrast of that comes
out in that previous passage.
We know that is probably big
woman and she has a of long,
they big hands, hips and so on. Uh,
we don't know exactly how big she is until
we get to see her through the eyes of
Richard Gordon.
And then is the kind of a
shock to see this passage, uh,
coming through the eyes of neutral,
uh,
hospital observer. Other than that,
I believe apple is in your top. Um,
but a very unkind,
neutral observer riding his bicycle.
It has a heavy said,
big blue eyed woman with bleach blonde
here showing under the old man's belt,
have her n across the row,
eyes red some crime.
Looking at that,
look at that big arcs with that.
What is it was a woman like that, things
that are well disciplined. She goes,
she does in bed.
What does your husband feel about
her when she gets their size?
In today's chapter, he was going to
use the big woman, but it's here.
And I would, the scene on
the way home. Her husband,
when he came home at night, he'd
ever hated the way she, of course,
and grown heavy sleep.
Hell, I had bleached hair.
The two big breasts he has
seen in the last of perception,
the whole inner life of death to happen.
Let.
So Hemingway is both dramatizing
the process of labeling
people making of social
types and
showing considerable,
uh, doubt whether that is at
the practice to say the least.
I'll get this really interesting
that Richard Gordon is a writer.
So,
you know,
I think the Hemingways probably thinking
about himself as well and where there
is an entirely ethical practice even to
populate his novel with Social Types of
thing.
Right now he's actually creating another
social type of writer who doesn't care
about subjects and wants to use them,
um,
to wreck novels to someone's
heart attack. Um, so, um, this is,
uh, he's both make talking
about, which of course may be
expressing a little bit of wearing
that himself as well. But in any case,
if we move away from Hemingway's
on investment and his psychology,
um, possible psychology, including
someone like Richard Gordon,
we can say that this is a
dry rag affirmation of what
a kind man Harry Morgan is
and is not just kindness
that enables him to look.
How's thickness of Maria is,
is probably the largest clients
on is understating the case.
It's something else are
there truly doesn't bother
me that she's so big when it
probably work, most people will
have noticed that about her. Uh,
so it says something about,
uh,
that relationship,
whatever we call it,
it is one that turns the big
woman to have you for one. Um,
and to the extent that Harry is able to
do that years ago in petitions so much,
he has a kind of emotional magic that
changes the re into something else.
And in the process of that transformation,
he also acquires an identity.
He is the person who's being able
to do this to me and do this for me.
This is the ultimate measure or someone
who has magic in his hand and it is the
lab of magic that makes me supporting
the water rather than he is Richard
Garland is, is, was probably once a
very, very good way. He, here's an IRA,
this was seat. We're thrilled to meet
him. Um, but at a point where meeting him,
he's waiting the crap around
you to be on the wane. Um,
and we begin to see those are
what a bad way that he is.
And this supposedly neutral a
portrait of Marie is that all,
you know, business is the size of this
woman. She doesn't want to listen to.
The most important fact about Marie is
that her eyes are red from prior to his
soul.
It if you're asking,
so the imagination that he
misses the central fact,
this is we're reading
knows that Eric is dead.
And that was why the eyes are to hear
random reticle is not a poor rhino.
Then he can ask you the most obvious
thing about from the way in this
eagerness to turn into a social time and
in this exchange views on why we see,
um,
that the fact that he's a bad driver.
I'm also always seems to spill out.
And as a kind of analogy,
uh, and his relation with his
wife Helen who leaving him. Uh,
and this is, um, this is actually
one of the great moments.
I'm not calling you with full
extent of, um, of Helen speech,
but go and look at page one wanting,
we filing this long,
long speech about love and um,
the is dripping with irony about what she
feels about lovely coming from Richard
Gordon. Um, but that is the end
of that conversation. All right,
I'm through with you and I'm
through with love. Your can pick,
knows love you.
Random you loan mix nuts sloughed.
Don't call me names. I know
with you all right. No,
not are all wrong. Ryan, if
you would, just a good writer.
I understand. Stand all the rest of it.
Maybe the last scene you bitter, jealous,
changing your politics
to suit the fashion,
sucking up to people's faces and talking
about them behind the Bads I've seen
you do on the city. Um,
so what kind of person,
which of course is can always
be register in full buyer.
Someone who's fired site all the time.
That is the most accurate picture of
Michigan and kind become person here.
So it is,
unfortunately,
they're completely cleans out
everything that we lose everything. Um,
his claim to fame is
claimed to craftsmanship is
cleaning to right region is
planes in Greg romantic Glover.
Um,
all those things have been emptied
out by Helen in this moment.
If we think about the
cemetery, the change, uh,
Harry channeled through Murray and
Richard Gordon channeled through Helen is
very quiet not to come to the conclusion
that we need to have an alternative
definition of what means to be a
half and what it means to be a,
have not,
um,
it's not so easy to add a label,
you know,
to what the criteria might be for cat,
for someone to can't have the criteria
on the much too complicated to be
captured as by one word.
That's really the point. Uh,
descends as way to put it as that,
in order to be a have you have to make
somebody else or have the read house of
her life because of Harry and Harry has
something because Marie has a good life.
This is symmetrical construction
of house in Hemingway's novels.
Um, so I would say that actually
this is, I'm having ways,
I often criticized for being the very
poor writer when it comes to women.
And that is true.
And I was with his mom,
his own imagination for what
my feel to be a woman. Uh,
but this is actually an
exception of Disney, how fall,
um, depiction of the human condition
from the woman's point of view.
And so, um, I, with in conclusion,
I like to bring up one celebrated a
passage for is writing a total from the
standpoint of a woman's point of view
and have just a little anecdote that
[inaudible] aeration for James Stores.
He saw James Joyce in Paris,
uh,
[inaudible] eating the sandwich and
they were all speaking Italian in Paris,
was very, very impressed. Um,
but so it was not an fitting, uh,
to compare him with choice in this most
famous passage in joy's Malia Soliloquy,
that [inaudible] of us'.
And I thought,
well as well him as another.
And then I asked him if
my eyes to ask again. Yes.
And then he asked me would I yes.
To say yes,
my mountain flower. And first
I put my arms around him. Yes.
And threw him down to the so he could
feel my breasts all perfume. Yes.
And his heart was going like man
and yes. I said yes, I will. Yes.
So this lovely blue thinking
of how long time ago, you know,
marriage has really gone sour
many ways. Um, [inaudible] um,
but thinking back to that moment when
she agrees to marry lyrical loo and um,
obviously whilst Angeles's from that note,
that very early romance we from to a
woman's love from man and a man slash
woman,
this is not quite,
not quite,
that is the opposite of that,
but I would argue is just as powerful
as well known as Molly Soliloquy.
Um, it was, how do you get through
it? Nice. If you can sleep,
I guess you find out that you
find out how it feels. How can,
I guess you find out all right.
I guess you find out everything and
discount them life I guess you do already
because I'm probably finding out
right now you just go dead inside and
everything is easy. You just get that.
Like most people are. Most of the time.
I guess that's how it is.
All right.
I guess that's just about what happens
to you. Well, I know the thought.
I've got a good star.
If that's what we have to do.
I guess that's where you'd have to
do. All right. I guess that's it.
I guess that's what it comes from.
All right.
I've got the start done and
where you're living now, um,
having all the sounds like Gertrude
Stein and other obvious favorite few,
and then it also sounds a little bit
anyway [inaudible] he really does sound
like, which is nice. Um, this
is kind of senseless repetition.
This is not elephant in compulsive
repetition on [inaudible] had a good life
taken away from her and so forth.
And the fact that
she's had a good life and in the fact
that it's just going hysterical when dad
is [inaudible] to come from him
and he doesn't want slowly yes,
social time.